a black hole is on a collision course
with our sun
and there's nothing left for you to do
except sit back and watch the
destruction of our entire solar system
how exactly would this epic collision
unfold
how would this black hole end up in our
planetary neighborhood
and
what would it be like to witness all
this from earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the sun collided with a black
hole
a black hole is not much different than
any other object that has mass
except it's dense
really dense
all the matter it possesses is
compressed to an infinitely small point
at its center called a singularity
most black holes are the remnants of
massive stars
and just like the stars they used to be
black holes have a strong gravitational
pull
the more matter compressed into its
singularity the stronger the gravity
there could be as many as 40 quintillion
black holes in the observable universe
many are located at the centers of their
galaxies like sagittarius a star
the closest known black hole to us
it resides right in the center of the
milky way
but black holes could also go rogue
after an extreme event like a collision
between two galaxies
a black hole can break free and start to
wander
there could be 12 of these rogue black
holes in our galaxy alone
and one could be headed toward the sun
right now
[Music]
if a wandering black hole were headed
toward our solar system it would first
reach the oort cloud
that's the sphere of icy objects
surrounding the solar system two light
years away from us
as soon as a black hole came too close
the icy bodies in this region would be
ejected from their orbits
you wouldn't be able to see the black
hole for yourself until it reached the
ice giants neptune and uranus
looking through a powerful telescope you
could see the gases being pulled away
from these planets all the gases and
dust torn from neptune and uranus would
form a region around the black hole
known as an accretion disk
this superheated collection of gas and
dust would orbit the black hole making
it visible
as it continued on its destructive path
you'd witness jupiter and saturn meet a
similar fate
you'd be able to see with your own naked
eye these gas giants disappearing from
our night sky
rocky inner planets like mars venus and
mercury would also be sucked into the
black hole and destroyed into
nothingness as you watched in horror
only earth would be spared
not really of course i just wouldn't
want you to miss out on your front row
ticket to the destruction of the solar
system
as the black hole approached our sun
you might think it would swallow it in
one blazing gulp
no instead the strong gravitational pull
would begin to pull matter from the sun
just like a strand being pulled from a
ball of yarn
huge portions of gas would be ripped
away from it and they would spin around
the black hole joining the accretion
disk formed by the gas and dust of all
our neighboring planets
this tearing apart of the sun would keep
going until our star no longer existed
what's left behind would be nothing more
than a gas cloud
only the very end of the tail of this
cloud might be able to escape the fate
of being pulled into the black hole
as the sun's matter was being absorbed
lethal amounts of ultraviolet and x-ray
radiation would be released in fiery
explosions
this radiation would be hurled right in
your direction back on earth
you wouldn't know the ultimate fate of
the sun for eight minutes
that's how long the light would take to
reach us but instead of the light source
of our solar system disappearing
entirely right away
the black hole itself could become
extremely bright
possibly trillions of times brighter
than the sun
and with the sun swallowed up the
stability of what's left in our solar
system would be completely destroyed
an entirely new gravitational balance
would need to be established
and in addition to all the lethal
radiation raining down on earth extreme
tidal forces would push and pull at the
planet
this would cause massive earthquakes
volcanic eruptions and tsunamis
eventually earth would crack into pieces
or maybe in the best case scenario
unceremoniously ejected from the solar
system
well the reality is you and everything
on our planet would be pulled right into
the accretion disk along with all the
other matter in our solar system
so now you'd have a new front row ticket
to the inside of a black hole
but
that's a story
for another
what if